the Joe Rogan experience I wear
flip-flops once a year it's when I go to
Hawaii
I I don't really wear flip-flops I don't
like the toe divider
I like slides you know slides I like
slides I [ __ ] with slides yeah I just
can't do flip I don't like the toe
divider weird weird meows where to draw
the line huh yeah yeah yeah what's
better Jamie you like slides slides
I don't worry yeah if I did a price a
lot of dudes will rock slides with white
socks yes and like serious dudes like
guys who go to the gym like muscular
young guys yep the oil slides and socks
and they'll go wandering about comfy if
you ever wear flip-flops and socks and
you went out with people would smack you
there's a difference for some reason
some guys can yeah but for some reason
slides and socks is acceptable wear
flip-flops and socks are not well cuz
then you do the Ninja Turtle toe you
can't do the socks with the flip-flops
because then your toe gets divided and
then it looks really weird but isn't
that strange
yeah well secure though the the both
ridiculous we're in slides of socks
looks ridiculous no it makes sense to me
but at least it looks casual right
slides with socks just I mean to wear
shoes man just slip my socks in these
and go to the [ __ ] don't go run over
there real fast you can go to the
grocery store with slides on and socks I
go to Bangalore say nothing nope
we go to the bank yeah I do small
errands with slides and socks on well
especially a guy like you you're a
successful comedian you make a good
living like you're not poor it's not
like there's the only pair of shoes you
have this is a choice yeah I've made it
obvious choice pull up in here Mercedes
I don't I don't have a Mercedes I'm
looking at right now no no I don't have
a Mercedes I bought yeah I bought a yeah
I'm giving back to the environment I
bought I have a Yaris I bought a Toyota
Yaris this is not true no you're saying
yeah that's true yeah white man with
your [ __ ] prison long first of all
slides our first regular boy I would
never buy Gucci [ __ ] that's insane I
bet a lot of goofs you know I buy the
adidas ones you can throw in the trash
oh is that why cuz if they're forget
[ __ ] up they're like 20 bucks he's
just buying his you're not into the
Gucci know you of all people asking me
that you would never wear Gucci [ __ ]
slides I have
Gucci slippers that my wife bought me
how often you wearing that warm twice
yogi exactly she bought him a couple
years ago they have Tigers on the on the
feet you know this you know this
hypebeast pervert over here he worried
all the time whoa whoa
you love that [ __ ] pervert you high
fever he's a height B's pervert he gets
he comes on he comes on you like to jack
off to like cool high peace [ __ ] you
know you do Wow whoa you don't either
line sir Jordans not where I'm like
whatever I saw what does that guy's name
Philip line how'd he said he's a um he's
the guy that got in trouble because they
took pictures he took pictures of his
sneakers he didn't get in trouble but
Ferrari got angry at him because he has
a Ferrari and he took pictures of his
sneaker sitting on his Ferrari so what
if Ferrari said that he they sent him
like a cease and desist saying that he's
damaging their brand his car is a
sneaker guy Philip Playa Playa nice he
he says it so there was a big
controversy because like he bought your
[ __ ] $300,000 car he should be able
take a picture of his sneakers on your
car like set it on fire he feels like it
what the [ __ ] his it was something about
his lifestyle that the lifestyle isn't
emotes but the lifestyle that he
promotes is just his hot girlfriend in
him and they're wearing clothes how do
they there's nothing crazy do you think
buys Ferraris yeah [ __ ] this is it so
yeah there's that's a dope color for
that has a beautiful [ __ ] color I've
never seen a green Ferrari threatens to
sue do that as a that makes me want to
make a Ferrari that colour that's a dope
colour yeah okay tarnishes the
reputation of Ferraris brands and causes
Ferrari further material damage that's
his behavior they'll lose that letter
tip lean also says that he was using
Ferraris trademarks for the promotional
purposes of increasing his own brand and
products visibility again the cars
pictured up Lions own Ferrari is
essentially claiming that plying is
harnessing its iconic imagery to bolster
his own brand and also denigrate
Ferraris how is it denigrating Ferraris
though like scroll back up it's just a
dope looking colour Ferrari and some
pretty [ __ ] cool sneakers those are
cool I don't understand how
denigrating the brand who do they think
is buying [ __ ] Ferraris like did they
have this idea that it's Harvard grads
that are buying Ferraris well some of
them were Harvard grads I think most
people that buy Ferrari didn't go to
Harvard do me a favor honestly a full
picture of his green Ferrari remember
like this before those pictures have
been taken off Instagram so like oh but
you see if you can just find his green
Ferrari because I know that [ __ ]
he's got a green Ferrari he takes a lot
of pictures of it there's no way that's
the only picture of his doped green you
would assume Ferraris brand is to
promote people who are like self-made
money making that's what this guy is
right is neither so there it is ago is
that it is that is there any other ones
other photos of it yeah see it's just
all his girlfriend looking hot and him
looking sexy and here's a dope car Lambo
yeah here's a my gold Lamborghini dope
here's my [ __ ] old plane jet it's got
a gold jet that's hilarious
it might be
[Applause]